it says that its cards with two sides
which I don't know what the mechanic is
to that but it's it's a double-sided
deck of dick why are you old mark what
do you mean quick call me Sonny
say mark old somehow sounds more rich
I'm in here now I'm in here so I
literally cannot enable sevens and zeros
oh I guess we're a play flip who know
which we have no idea how this works
completely new e brought to you by
eclipse new collection of clothes if
you're not see swag cloak brand.com come
now you really got downhill I think it's
really you'd be wrong it's gone up in
quality and down in price more
affordable better clothes Ringo that's
totally the lady from lady in the [ __ ]
her name definitely was Ringo also I can
see all your car oh I don't know doll oh
just flip my changed yeah we all saw
that thank you
oh my what is this color these colors
almost as good as the new colors from
cloak brand calm vibrant beautiful
colors available to you right now what
the f what is this to change the colors
I like how bright the colors are I'm
challenging why why am i challenging
don't challenge me it's that 100 no okay
i I don't I don't have any those things
hey look it's a push to push wait look I
wanted it to be a plus four because
that's what I know and understand and
this new stuff scares me everything
everything different is wrong and it's
not good okay here it is the double
still alright cool good horse hi what is
this two one I'm just gonna say that
like I don't know exactly what I'm doing
every time why I thought for sure in 14
cards you had a single plus one and dude
no no yeah you should see my flip side
though it looks like they're pretty lame
actually from what I could see no come
on man no way one one car that looks
interesting I'm all yours that's what
that's what I see when I look at your
face one part your nose yeah thanks for
the assist Bob yeah what color is weird
orange how do we know what colors what
on the other side its colors yeah it's
just the four four and four I think
that's what you sound like
yeah yeah I didn't do that but I did do
this one that's just unnecessary I know
but you know highly irregular
I do ah wait what about some of this I
don't know mark you devious wait would
you be able to know what color he has on
the flip side do they correspond
directly
do they correspond directly wait what oh
oh sorry mark dude I see a jump in I
jump in I mean I don't think it was his
turn anyway it was the game of flip
anyone who's ever played in the world
you're right probably you're right
thank can I get it you right can I get
it you right right here yeah are you
right you right no no in my soundboard
someone give me a you right you right
you right no that's not right
am I not doing it am i right that's more
of a right you right you know what you
wrong you right oh yeah and 100 I don't
even get a chance to do anything other
than make noises I didn't get a you
right Oh God because my my sound board
is not activated right now oops
Oh I wrong I wrong I wrong okay it's on
now
Oh God site not found what the hell is
that
oh god no God no oh god no oh god no
okay here we go we're good moaning noise
oh oh god yes is that what you wanted
you really really enjoying that over
there huh this one play don't ask
booing it's my sound board I'm what do
you going I gets on random I can't
select which one blue well then I didn't
hear the same once alright now wait a
minute
I'll let South take Oh
challenge me come on man oh no no no
I've learned my lesson but I want you to
challenge me then did we fight we
weren't fighting what do you mean we
hated each other TV what's afterwards to
make up for it what wait what I paid it
to you my entire life okay but I'm
learning to get past it you know you
know man behind your back I always say
that Bob I love that Bob is such a good
friend that's what I say what do you say
I'm trying to convince people that
you're you're somehow involved in in in
in in the in stock markets which
everyone hates okay I have some stocks
but you are you know come on man
no this guy 100 shares the Chiquita
banana you're gonna sell
no no it's low right now I can't sell
what are you talking about about bear
markets look at this guy oh wait you're
supposed to play a card eventually there
you go yeah I don't know what this does
but I think it means flip our thingies
hey there we go turns out my cards are
just as boring as I imagined them to be
[Music]
don't even know it dude
worth the ultra reverse I don't know
what can't we know savage over here God
why would you do that I will not we're
going back to the side I know God
without the +5 like normal side
I like normal side normal sides good I
like drains the deck when we flip the
cards back and forth Oh would you could
you suck one that doesn't make ring gay
or swear on the fridge oh good job buddy
that's good man you've been working on
that one yeah I have a really good whose
accent were you mocking him or me I was
actually in both of you I don't know if
this was smart to do I have no idea I
don't know look don't challenge me fool
you walked into my trap card and so
forth you fell for me just see what yeah
I'm gonna find a way to +5 you again
okay why did you throw it what you okay
cuz I blew my hand was on the keyboard
so I had to click to get the what you
could've slop haha you have frozen or am
i dying because yeah mark you're picking
a color right now no no I'm not what
color what's on the board I'll try and
play good screen right now I don't have
any of that well I can't do anything
well dagnabbit it's not countdown
anything I think maybe it's just frozen
is this a feature of the new game mode
is this a flip thing hmm this this
intermission brought to you by cloak
brand da da Gama
don't know Home Collection it is
spectacular you want yourself listen
you're gonna if you're gonna advertise
that stuff I need a new pair of sweat
pants I've ripped mine you guys I need
dude you send me sizes I'll get you
cloak that sounds nice it's a nucleus
make any purple stuff I saw I saw some
green stuff some neon stuff in this new
collection there's some purple like
accents
I'm more
airing a pink one right now but we don't
even or Scottish accent if you have you
will have much of the
powerful Scottish accents along today
Brenda wait wait why my why am i
promoted wait take over if to you give
me a cloak promo come on give me give me
some thanks man thank you
look I'm gonna just altar for my way out
of this situation
hey Bobby played cool right should we
back I see okay nightmare song we're
using oh that's the Mickey Mouse song
yeah yeah you know Bob you have some
good cards on your flip side we never
have to see it oh my god yeah getting
rid of them baby yeah you are that would
have been like a game-winner thirty no
I'm full skip up to two full skips plus
five and then a deck flip whatever the
deck is I don't even know what that is
but I'm afraid of it well isn't that the
one that just makes us flip the cards
over how why would you pick that color
yeah it's like the worst pick if you're
gonna not mute it could you at least
Michael Jackson's knees for us there's
no way that wasn't a soundboard I'm
gonna stack it
well I guess you both got it
turn thanks man thank you thanks mark
you're welcome here for you buddy two
separate games of uno yeah I feel like
it's some cool colors but I don't like I
don't want a [ __ ] talk thing I don't
fully understand maybe I'm missing
something but isn't this just regular
who know without some of the rules that
make regular who know kind of funny hey
man I was busy
I'm have what just happened there was
blade why did you there is respect I see
when I jump in mark and they leave you
said it's got a waited and waited a turn
at done the same thing not giving me a
plus-one though but I'm not sound
boarding you but but I it's just me jump
in you know I'm talking about that was
blue they played that to change the
challenge it oh it's okay well never
mind I would like to play now I know
okay okay
boring
garbage doesn't matter what side I'm on
it's always boring Oh what is this dude
it just changes the color it's a draw
one maybe it's a draw every number
that's below that card here let's see
this just popped up this is this is like
you don't need that oh my god oh my god
that was Green five crap leave it up to
the random I'm sure that I will be 14
now mushroom oh my gosh me oh well here
goes my chances of winning guys go right
down the drain whoa calm down
don't do it okay wait you didn't wait no
more
parts than I have somehow wait these
aren't half boo is the thing you don't
know you can take it for me take the hit
lower the burden done lower the burden
oh no no you Archie come on guys I will
decline it then I won't get any cards
one why and how this is what you get
what you get that is what you get if I
do
let's go back to do anyway good good
jump in myself apparently say my turn
no is it breaking again I'm not able to
play Oh that card is a draw until you
get the color of the person chose is it
broken again is it a bug of like if you
jump in as soon as you come back flip
over the in there might literally be a
game bug oh no did you literally break
your game you have probably you have one
job so is it is it my turn
no it's Mark's turn right now right no I
mean I returned I think that's what it
must be so whenever we flip don't jump
in actually maybe we should turn off
jump in I think that's the bug I could
do that okay well some slight issues
jump in is turned off this intermission
brought to you by cloak brand.com get
yourself some of the spiciest most
delectable new styles
in the most vibrant outrageous new
colors these sweet joggers oh my god
you can't block this ad you can't it's
live it's here it's now come on man Wow
look I just sit around and I think of
you guys doing meow meow meow that's
awesome man I'm streaming the day I was
like what's the thing Bob does with the
meows yes I came up with that I don't
know who did the inventor and originator
of that bit among our group it was Bob
it's me the whole time you know I don't
know why I'm trying to clamor for the
right to that get a March II gotta
marchi are you just Barbra and cat form
I mean it's cat I wait you like pets
I do cats I've never been anything but a
holes to me Keener's wasn't but every
other cat I've known it's been a real
a-hole oh that said oh I was gonna play
but and then I realized it was to skip
me yeah you should challenge it cuz it's
yellow oh wow he's really trying to pull
one over on you mm-hmm dick Archie well
that's a little aggressive that's pretty
rude man okay wait what no I don't like
I get my heart rate just spiked
literally legitimately you know I dead
see
honest to god honest good that was that
was what I was gonna
I know I'm really nice to you all day
yesterday but we didn't talk you know I
was like man wait looks great today I
wish I could tell him here we go here
yesterday well you're welcome in the
past it's just give you another nerd
don't could just be refresh but I like
that the game takes the effort to be
like not you not you not you
oh dear colors colors Oh dog challenges
do not challenge grew you a hole how
many oh dear wait okay so what what is
the you have to draw and to get the
color they selected but then that's when
I fail a challenge I also then seem to
have to draw too
draw an extra two interesting so it's
like it draw some then plus two
fascinating yay back in the hole oh if
you guys could stop skipping me I just
want to make sure the game is working
you no no no this is guys get ready for
some of this Bob make it make it pink
the pink isn't even a color except on
these cloak brand shirt I'm wearing
excellent color excellent color wait
what have you done to me nothing as bad
as what we did to Archie [ __ ] oh wait a
minute
wait wait well I guess my complaining is
not gonna accomplish anything okay looks
like it's not valid oh sorry I'm losing
connection oh god oh god
oh no one saw it that's so sad for you
I got +10 after you that's so good for
you man that's so man no you had one job
like deck can we try normal mode they
hopefully didn't touch so works should I
turn jumping back on or leave it off you
know it is a day of release so they're
probably our problems I get it today
yeah today of course I forgot to change
my game category that's what mods are
for therefore they forgot that is true
yeah that's a mod stupid corner your
jobs come to here volunteer jobs - oh
your god damn why not pay you for this
is just basic [ __ ] you know with with
some spice right with some spicy rules
[Music]
its ow
get a mouth I just wanna make sure
you're good and connected double check
to make sure did not want this I gave
away some good stuff for this this is
not red buddy I can't what do you think
I'm doing my hand back this is far from
ideal
if yours better than Al's hanwen or this
hand makes me wanna go cry myself to
sleep sorry about why would you do that
I had no choice had no choice he
challenged
you should believe me today he's got
yellow-yellow-blue yellow-yellow-indigo
no probably not man no I guess I'll just
play a 5 that's cool whoa yellow-green
hmm
mark do something with I can do
something with this I can I can then
definitely do something with this man I
was excited to use that on you and now
you're using it on Bob yeah challenge me
idea I don't want to win so I definitely
challenge you all right fair good yeah
game less oh that's a lot at the
beginning be nice to me al dusty
Thank You al hi I like my scary al dusty
[Laughter]
[Music]
challenge you please that's good stuff
man
one of these numbers why is it green
okay you're just being rude for the sake
of being rude now what do you want it to
be Bob what do you want to be
I have all four colors plus two well
[Laughter]
that's Albus what else sounds like man
you're killing it Bob you're killing my
own personal belief yeah you've been
doing nothing but that this whole time
get him up yeah I'll get a mr. dust
together you might have gotten me worse
unless this is a read and it is Wow 5%
chance there Oh
dust oh I was mean we'd go again well
didn't do it didn't it didn't need was
gonna happen
oh boy don't call - no laughs wow so
many sixes ready to rock
[Music]